what's happened is that the consumer
mindset and the business mindset has
been
crushed with fear throughout this
pandemic and the restaurant industry
specifically has been vilified
as these vectors have spread and that is
so wrong that's not the case at all from
the very beginning i said look we should
be used
as the proper models through which we
can you know
exhibit to everybody that you can
operate in a safe manner restaurants
inherently pre-pandemic are trained and
taught to focus on
safety sanitation surf food handler
certificates
were in some cases probably more
sanitary than certain
medical environments but yet we have
become
the fictitious villains of the pandemic
when none of the data and none of the
science proves that
we went i don't know if you know the
restaurant boa in west hollywood or
beverly hills it's my favorite steak
joint in la we i took my team there last
week for my producer's birthday
i love that place the food is awesome
the atmosphere is great but this was the
first time
indoors since this whole thing you know
they had to do what they had to do so
it's separated you know the guys have
masks the waiters with masks and face
shields nobody's sitting at the bar
anymore
they can't do the table side caesar and
it was like we had a great time
but it was it just didn't feel right to
me it just kind of didn't feel right
are you worried that as things continue
to open up that just getting the
atmosphere back
is is going to be tricky and also
people's ability to like want to sit at
a bar
and talk to somebody i miss that
yeah the fear is palpable and it's
coming through in the design the
branding and every single element of the
restaurant industry and that
is an in that is intentional in my
opinion right because what's happened is
that
the consumer mindset and the business
mindset has been crushed with
fear throughout this pandemic and the
restaurant industry specifically has
been
vilified as these vectors have spread
and that is so wrong that's not the case
at all from the very beginning i said
look we should be used
as the proper models through which we
can you know
exhibit to everybody that you can
operate in a safe manner restaurants
inherently pre-pandemic are trained and
taught to focus on
safety sanitation serv-safe food handler
certificates
we're in some cases probably more
sanitary than certain
medical environments but yet we have
become
the fictitious villains of the pandemic
when none of the data and none of the
science proves that
and we've absorbed it right so now it's
these restaurant tours kind of
tip-toeing through and hoping that they
don't get canceled or that a private
facebook group doesn't take a photo of
somebody without a mask
you know it's it's it really is
unfortunate it's going to put the
industry back
years what kind of crazy nonsense have
you had to do well i don't even know
where
so what's going on in oc right now are
you guys somewhat open indoors what
what's the regulation as we speak right
now yeah 50
indoors um we can dine outdoors now
which is huge
and uh you know obviously there's all
those kind of little levers that you
need to put in place in regards to
operations are still there
but people are scared i mean that's the
reality of the situation whether it's oc
whether it's
la um you know people kind of try and
draw the distinction between the two but
it's not as distinct as
as many would suggest um you know and of
course there's there's a political
tribalism that runs through a lot of it
and i tell people the stories it's funny
me personally i have been the target of
a lot of ire here in orange county
and we from day one have been
really vocal about how we can follow the
rules but also
open and operate properly and that we
are safe spaces
for people who want to get out but also
feel free
and can eat um independent of fear from
covet
where you were people don't yeah were
you worried that as you kind of spoke
out more against
lockdowns and some of this stuff they
were talking about here that because
you're political you know because
everything sort of then becomes
political
that that was going to have a cost
of course of course um but it was after
i spoke out
uh against newsome span on outdoor
dining it was full panic right
hitting every single outlet from new
york post to what what have you right
this this
this little rant that i went on in my
own kitchen went completely viral
and my phone was blowing up with with
positive and negative comments you name
it
um but then what started to happen was
people started to support the business
from afar people were calling up saying
hey
i just run a thousand dollars on my
credit card i appreciate you speaking
out
and i realized at that moment that it
was true people had talked about this
idea that the people who cancel you are
not the people spending money at your
business
and it really rang true i mean look
since we've been vocal and not
i don't think that we've been vocal in
the sense of offending anybody we've
just been very
principled with our positions and
supporting those in the restaurant
industry our sales have been up 300 400
percent in certain
certain circuits yeah when that happened
that shutdown or i guess it was maybe
the second shutdown it's hard to
remember the
order of all this but that outdoor ban
when when sheila cool
supervisor sheila cool here in la
announced she was the 3-2 deciding vote
to shut down outdoor dining
and then she went to eat outdoors in
santa monica to her favorite italian
restaurant
that to me was the one that like snapped
me i was at her house the next day
protesting because i was like this
like this is now beyond just beyond the
pal
yeah and you know i was getting messages
emails phone calls from
hundreds of restaurant owners in la and
orange county
all of whom are you know died in blue
democrats
yeah and and just absolutely livid
and it was at that point that i realized
that this is a non-partisan issue you
can make anything partisan
but really when we start to watch the
people who are setting the rules
breaking their own rules and then it's
literally crushing the businesses people
who put their blood sweat and tears into
it
now suddenly people's eyes open up so
from sheila cool going to a restaurant
let's talk
about our governor i know you're not a
fan of mr newsome
that's not even a question just talk
about him
look you know i i i i would love to be
able to sit down in a room with newsome
and try and
understand what's driving a lot of his
decisions because he's very very
eloquent he's well spoken
sometimes he does seem principled we
know who's
driving a lot of his decisions he's
tribal with the ways in which he makes
decisions
he's a good team player for those that
are within his political sphere and i
give them that
but through the pandemic it went beyond
those partisan lines and he started to
do things
to fundamentally alter the ways in which
a lot of us in california operate and
look at local governments and state
governments
and i think that he was trying to set a
new baseline nationally
by out of his peers to say look at how
far i can go this is what we can do in
california
and look biden even echoed that message
when he said california
is really the example by which we should
all go the entire country
and a lot of that went to his head
clearly but when he started to break his
own rules
and this arrogant nature of his comments
about that
started to get you know replayed over
and over again on all these outlets and
then he would double down on it
it made me realize that his narcissism
was in full effect and i don't even know
if he was a human making those decisions
or some sort of aerobic 18 grand
on booze alone at french laundry that's
a lot of booze
how much beer would i have to buy a slap
fish for 18 grand on taco tuesday we're
going two dollars so you know you do the
math divide by two carry the zero
that's that that's a lot of booze that's
a lot of booze
um all right so it came with some some
cost but obviously some benefit
i i sense you're kind of actually
digging this this new direction just for
you personally
um it's tough right it's a juggle um but
i think it all still does come back to
food and that's what i've said from the
very beginning food is the great
connector
right it is the great unifier when it
comes to food
i mean you you know you can put all of
your
differences aside and argue over whether
it's pineapple on pizza or whether it's
you know toasting two sides of a grilled
cheese sandwich people very quickly
forget about the reasons
and we do need a little bit of that
unity right now and i'm not trying to
sing kumbaya
but i do feel that food is the vehicle
through which we can get there
if you're looking for more honest and
thoughtful conversations about politics
instead of non-stop yelling check out
our politics playlist and if you want to
watch full interviews on a variety of
topics watch our full episode playlist
all right over here and to get notified
of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
bell